hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round six of this
year's Fay Grand Swiss uh it's uh in my
opinion definitely the game of the round
could be very well the game of the
tournament I'm not going to say it's the
game of the year or anything but it is
truly incredible it is bascaran adiban
versus Eduardo toaga Bonelli and uh
let's let's just see the game so um
basaran has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to C5
um taga goes for for the Sicilian
Defense Knight F3 E6 and D4 we have
captures captures and now A6 the con
variation of the Sicilian uh we have
Bishop to D3 the main line against the
con Bishop to C5 this is the POI
variation and now Knight B3 attacks the
bishop Bishop back to E7 and Knight to
C3 we have D6 and okay the position has
been reached before some popular uh
games were continued with castles Pawn
to F4 Bishop to E3 uh Pawn to A4 but
here we have Queen to E2 very very rare
we have Knight to F6 and now there are a
couple of more games that reach this
position but after Pawn to F4 uh it is
now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so okay Knight to C6
we have Bishop to E3 and pawn to B5 so
we might have castles on opposite sides
of the body White Castles Queen side
black Castle King side uh we have uh
castles Queen side and queen to C7 first
we have King to B1 always useful and now
Rook to B8 preparing to advance the pawn
to B4 uh Pawn to G4 preparing Pawn to G5
and pawn to H6 stopping that so H4
preparing that and now black even plays
um Pawn to H5 himself he doesn't want to
wait for H5 and then G5 so he plays this
forces G5 G5 and Knight G4 attacks the
dark Square Bishop on D3 and this is um
also something that's really incredible
about this game uh how this bishop on E3
can constantly be C Capt but really it
can't so here you might try something
like Rook HD1 as The Rook is no longer
useful on the H file but not adiban
adiban plays Pawn to G6 so how do you
react to this uh probably safest is just
the castle but itaga goes for Pawn to B4
attacks the Knight on C3 and now G
captures on F7 and okay again you might
capture but no Eduardo goes for King to
f8 he wants to use the uh the white Pawn
as a shield uh so you cannot attack the
black king but this allows um uh for
some very interesting tactics we have
Knight to A4 getting the Knight out of
Harm's Way and now Pawn to E5 uh putting
pressure on on on this nice Center and
now if you advance the pawn to F5 which
looks like a great move uh it doesn't
really do all that much you're just
going to trade on E3 um then develop the
bishop and the black will have a very
nice game however here we have Bishop to
C4 and now how can black continue this
uh well you should really capture the
bishop on E3 starting with that is
definitely the way to go but Eduardo
played Bishop to D7 and uh from this
point on Black's position is just dead
lost and it's amazing how bascaran
adiban accomplishes that so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for white while I give you
a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting this incredible line and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is night 8 to C5 this is the
move and uh once again big
congratulations if you've spotted this
because it really requires you to
calculate point is that we have to see
what happens if the bishop uh just moves
okay if you don't capture the Knight can
we do that so let's try this uh well no
after Knight to E6 with check Forks the
king and the queen you will have to give
up the bishop now the pawn is nicely
defended and after let's say captures
and
captures there's really no good move
that you can play here uh capturing an
F4 Queen captures doesn't really do all
that much the king will be stuck here
you will have very nice pressure on the
D6 Pawn uh if you try something like
Rook to H6 and don't capture on F4 then
F5 now your king is stuck here your Rook
cannot get into the game the bishop is
useless uh it's uh it's it's a really
bad position for black so you can't just
do nothing so D captures on C was played
and it is objectively the best move but
now what was um adan's idea Rook
captures on D7 so he has to continue
happily sacrificing pieces in order to
uh accomplish his Opera game Queen
captures on D7 and now Knight captures
on C5 and here is the big question do
you play Bishop captures on C5 and allow
this um Bishop to come to C5 thus
creating the the bishop pair from Hell
or do you just move the queen well there
is no good Square for the queen and this
is probably the hardest variation to
comp to calculate in the game let's say
you play Queen to D6 which is the top
move recommended by the engine uh Knight
to E6 check comes and now you are forced
to capture here so King captures now
comes Bishop to C5 the bishop does get
to this diagonal and after the queen
moves as this is the only Square
available to the black queen now you
even bring the Knight into the The Rook
into the game and after the queen moves
now you go Knight to G5 with check this
is now a double check from the bishop
and the Knight King to f8 and now Bishop
to E6 attacking the queen and once you
move the queen and there really aren't
all that many great squares for the
queen uh for example if you if you go
here then you can even capture the
knight uh and then black cannot
recapture due to Knight E6 check winning
the black queen if you go to E8 which is
also can be done then Bishop to D7 comes
and now look at how you trap the queen
queen to G6 Queen to C4 now take away
all the squares from the Black King and
now Knight to E6 check will just be
deadly uh so whatever you play as you
don't really have a move let's say Rook
d8 even F5 can be played and now after
Queen F6 now you're going to go Knight
to E6 check and that's it King to G8
Knight captures on d8 opens up a
discovery here King to H7 you're just
going to collect all the material and
that's pretty much it if Bishop captures
and C5 Queen captures and you're you're
down a piece in a terrible unplayable
position so that that's the hardest part
to calculate in this game what happens
if you don't capture so that's what
happens so he had to capture Bishop
captures on C5 now comes Bishop captures
uh you have to block Knight D7 and now
Rook to D1 the queen The Rook comes into
the game with Tempo on the D file uh
same as in morphy's famous opera house
game Queen to C6 and now Queen to D3 uh
offering a full Bishop but of course it
cannot be captured because Queen to d8
would be checkmate with a very nice
Queen sacrifice so instead we have PA
Pawn to G5 freeing up the G7 Square for
the king and also if black somehow
survives this you might get a pass Pawn
at the end of this line and uh What uh
do you play here well objectively best
is just Bishop captures on B4 uh it
comes with the pretty much the same idea
that the uh Bishop cannot be captured
because if you capture then Queen to d8
check King G7 and now you capture The
Rook on h8 and after King captures f8
Queen and after King H7 you capture on E
s and now everything just Falls King to
h8 Rook to d8 with check you don't even
have to go for material because it will
be Checkmate so what happened after G5
was not Bishop captures on B4 and also
yeah if you if you just do nothing then
Queen to A3 will be incredible I mean
look at this bishop pair and then it
will be even further empowered by the
queen on A3 uh amazing amazing stuff but
um adiban wanted to wanted to finish the
Masterpiece now and he played Queen to
d8 check he s sacrifice this queen which
objectively might not be the most
precise way to do it but it is very very
hard to defend this Rook captures on8
was played Rook captures with check King
G7 and now Rook captures on h8 now uh
threatening to bring the um uh Queen
into the game with f8 queen and even if
you capture The Rook it doesn't help you
if you don't capture The Rook it doesn't
help you so what's the only way to
defend Knight to G6 and now Rook to G8
with check King to H7 and now Pawn to F5
kicking out the defender of the f8
square uh but now Knight to f8 a very
tricky defense by Eduardo uh forcing
forcing adiban to waste a move here
Bishop captures on f8 and now uh the
real uh reason why the queen sacrifice
does not work here black can actually
defend this position but I mean who who
who would find this in a position like
this uh feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only defensive resource
for black to survive the game while I
give you a couple coup of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh uh
being very very uh cool in in difficult
positions And for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is not well
it's not that it's not this it's
actually Queen captures on e4 and for a
very simple reason after Queen captures
on e4 yes you are threatening Checkmate
everyone can see that but the point is
after Rook to G7 check and King h8 once
you play B3 you have a Perpetual Queen
E1 check followed by Queen to C3 check
that's the point Queen E1 check Queen to
C3 check and you have a a Perpetual in
the game after Bishop captures on f8 he
did not capture on e4 he played a queen
captures on C4 uh which seems like it's
the exact same idea uh only you grab a
piece and you might even end up having
winning chances like we said maybe G
captures on H4 ends up giving black a
pass Pawn uh the problem is now uh it
doesn't work and because of Rook G7
check King to h8 okay they repeat a few
times Rook to G7 check King h8 and B3
now look at this queen to F1 with check
King B2 and you don't have this
Perpetual so you have to waste the move
to prepare it Queen to A1 was played and
now it seems like okay now white plays
something and I get my Perpetual that's
how this is going to end up but no now
actually Adan has Bishop captures on B4
and you don't have the B4 pawn and now
uh sorry not not right away first the
position was repeated once again and now
Bishop captures on B4 and now you don't
have a perpetual and f8 queen is coming
how do you stop this well Queen captures
on B4 stops f8 Queen but now Rook to G8
with check King to H7 and f8 queen uh
finally adiban gets the other Queen into
the game Queen captures Rook captures
and now G captures on H4 so even this
now has to be played out because now uh
how do you stop the past Pawn PA well
adiman says it's not a problem
whatsoever just Pawn to F6 and now the
reason why you stop the pawn is that
after H3 F7 and now the threat is Rook
to h8 check followed by f8 Queen so you
have to stop this but now still Rook to
h8 incredible stuff here King captures
on F7 uh Rook captures on H5 and the
pawn is now U stopped even if you get it
to H2 it doesn't really matter white
just starts pushing and the queen side
pawns are much faster uh it's some Point
even if you somehow get the king to G2
and promote this Pawn to a queen The
Rook will sacrifice itself for the queen
and then you will your pass pawns on the
queen side will win the game so after F6
King to G6 was played now comes Pawn to
F7 and now Knight to F6 now this is a
trick uh because if King if Rook to h8
is played now then just King captures on
F7 and the H5 Pawn is defended so you
can't play that however pawns start
marching forward Pawn to C4 we have Pawn
to H3 Rook to G8 with check giving up
the F7 Pawn to stop the advanced H Pawn
so King captures Rook to G3 and now
Knight captures on e4 if you go for H2
doesn't really work H3 and now after
Knight G4 defending the pawn Rook
captures on H5 and we end up with a
position that we already discussed at
some point The Rook will uh be
sacrificed for for the pawn or for the
newly appointed Queen and that's pretty
much it so Knight captures an E4 was
played Rook captures on H3 and now King
to G6 okay Eduardo still in the game uh
Pawn to B E4 now it's time to create a
pass pawn and another pass Pawn on the
queen side King to G5 Now Pawn to C5 and
pawn to H4 we have Rook to E3 now uh
King to F4 defending uh and now adiban
calculates it U one more time he doesn't
he shows that he's not tired after
calculating all of this throughout the
game he plays Rook captures on e4 King
captures and paon to C6 paon to H3 C7 H2
and now C8 Queen Eduardo also Queens but
look at the diagonal that's the problem
Queen to C6 with check and he was in
this position and move 56 that Eduardo
toaga Bonelli resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so
beautifully played by bascar and adiban
truly a masterpiece I'm definitely uh
saying it's the it's the game of the
round uh could be the game of the
tournament if it's more you guys will be
the judges of that but I I I just want
to show you the game uh but what's also
very interesting is that when you have
this position on the board and it's time
to conclude the game how do you decide
what which check to give this is also
very interesting to me because I would
give Queen to A8 check uh you know to to
make it uh this to me is visually much
more appealing than Queen to C6 so I'm
sure uh adiban had his reason for
playing Queen to C6 maybe I don't know
could be could be whatever reason uh
maybe he just likes the C6 Square uh
maybe it was uh poetic as the black
queen was on C6 when adiban first
sacrificed his Queen on d8 I have no
idea why why but I just find it
interesting uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh do share
what you think is it the game of the
round game of the the game of the what
uh uh I mean it is a brilliant game I'm
I'm calling at adan's Knight at the
Opera so let's just keep it at that uh
so yeah once again really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Mario
Milano the BR on Spotify Steven mccan
chess uh beats league and Roman manini
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day